spider-man far from home catches up with
your friendly neighborhood wall-crawler
as he heads out of Queens for a
wide-ranging field trip through the best
touristy vistas that Europe has to offer
but it's not all fun and games on this
journey abroad let's break it all down
with some small details you may have
missed in the movies first trailer the
first far from a home trailer includes a
close-up shots of Peter Parker's
passport in which Tom Holland still
somehow manages to look like a movie
star
in spite of an intentionally goofy photo
while the passport lacks any specific
years on any of its state sections it
does include a cute nod to spider-man's
real-life comic book origins pausing the
video to take in all the details
viewers may notice that Peter Parker's
birthday is listed as August 10th a
seemingly inconsequential bit of trivia
what you may not have realized as our
August 10th really is the day that
spider-man as we know him was born with
the character making his first
appearance on a comic book on that date
way back in 1962 an amazing fantasy
issue 15 written and penciled by Stan
Lee and Steve Ditko while the characters
origins would be told and retold many
times over many comic issues over the
years to come all the core details are
there in his initial appearance Peter's
now a canonical date of birth in the MCU
it's a great tip of the hat to the day
that got to solve franchise started much
of the first far from home trailer
showcases Peter making his way around
Europe in a sleek new suit designed with
red and black colors while it looked
similar to the red and blue suits he
sported in Captain America Civil War and
spider-man homecoming the far from home
trailers new suit seems to once again
pay tribute to Steve Ditko's original
comic book cover design which seems to
feature a suit that's almost more black
than blue even more interestingly this
isn't the only change of clothes we see
Spidey wear in the trailer towards the
end we get a glimpse of a new stealthy
looking black costume as spider-man
seems to be wearing during a night
mission it's safe to assume it came from
Nick Fury though we'll have to wait
until we see the movie to know for sure
meanwhile this can be seen as yet
another reference to a couple of now
classic Spidey looks from the comics the
spider-man noir suit and of course
spider-man's original black suit in an
act of mercy to moviegoers everywhere
the MCU entries in the spider-man Canon
have so
Phar spared us yet another death scene
for poor old Uncle Ben sure sure with
great power must also come great
responsibility but we don't need another
origin story with been eating a street
thugs bullet to get the point anymore
while the character played a major part
in the Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
spider-man movies Peters beloved uncle
isn't expected to make an on-screen
appearance in the Tom Holland movies but
despite his physical absence from the
franchise his presence still looms large
over Peter Parker's story in spider-man
homecoming Peter alluded to a desire to
protect art made from an jus spider-man
related stress me cannot no I cannot do
that to her right now
you know I mean everything that's
happening with her I pshh
it's a great way to tell the story that
so many of us already know letting
viewers engage with the movie by filling
in the blanks themselves far from home
takes us throughout further were the
initials BFP stitched onto Peters
luggage visible in the center of frame
while he's packing for his trip to
Europe these are this shells probably
belong to Uncle Ben F Parker it's a
heartwarming better sweet touch to
include in the movie implying that the
matter where Peter goes on his
adventures whether it's across the pond
to Europe or beyond the stars to Titan
he'll always be carrying a little bit of
his Uncle Ben with him picking up with a
la spider-man movie left off far from
homes first trailer starts with
spider-man and Aunt May standing side by
side at a charitable benefits with may
having full knowledge of the superheroes
real-life identity then happy Hogan Tony
Stark's loyal consistently harried
assistant shows up to spider-man's
charity fundraiser with a giant novelty
check from the stark relief foundation
signed by none other than Pepper Potts
the sequence of events seems to imply
that whatever happens in Avengers
endgame Pepper Potts will make it out
alive otherwise this reference would
come off a little bit morbid one thing
that's less clear is just exactly what
happened to Tony Stark I am mom was a
pretty big part of pizzas life in
spider-man homecoming and Avengers
infinity war and the presence of happy
and pepper with Tony nowhere in sight
it's a little bit worrisome we don't
want to draw conclusions as he at least
made it back from space yet the far from
home trailer includes glimpses of
several new bad guys including a being
made out of water
a fiery monster and
tannic bruiser who appears to be made
out of sand and let's not forget the
curacy violence lightning bolts flying
around during an action sequence at
London's Tower Bridge the enemies all
appeared to be reminiscent of some key
villains from spider-man's comic past
including molten man Sandman
Hydra man and potentially electro but
are these monsters really classic Spidey
villains or are they something different
well there's one detail you might have
missed that could indicate the former /
the latter pour pizzas best friend the
net leads has his picture taken in
Venice you can see a boat in the
background floating by with a SM - 1 2
printed boldly on its side did that
combination of letters and numbers
tickle your spider sense if so there's a
pretty good reason for it the text has a
clear reference to the two hundred and
twelfth issue of amazing spider-man
published in January 1981 featuring the
very first appearance of Morris bench
the villain also known as Hydra man it's
too soon to say if far from home
features a specific version of the
character or for these monsters are
something else entirely but either way
this little code on the boat is a nice
nod to Spidey's past the tail end of the
far from home trailer features the grand
entrance of jake gyllenhaal of Mysterio
making his debut on the silver screen in
a dramatic way you don't want any part
of this wall Mysterio has long been
spider-man's enemy and Marvel Comics
here he shows up to fight as a hero or
at least that's how things appear to be
in the comics Mysterio whose real name
is Quintin Beck is a stuntman and
special effects expert for the movie
business who uses elaborate illusions to
appear as though he's welding real magic
usually for the sake of committing
crimes
it obviously begs the question is this
trailer pulling a trick on us after
Mysterio shows up to take over the fight
against a gigantic creature made of
water his exploits end up on a news
broadcast crediting the mystery man for
fighting back the threat sure it's
possible that Mysterio is just here to
help but what if their special effects
wizard was using high-tech illusions to
make these fights happen engineering
himself a heroic moments at the expense
of spider-man and countless civilians we
can't tell for sure just yet but the way
the fight works out for Quinton's
benefits is definitely a little miss
Arius check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about spider-man and the MCU
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]